i started watching it during the day
with friends and then i
watched the rest of the episodes all in
one night so i could not i was literally
up to like three in the morning which i
don't do so as you all might know
i love binge watching tv and during the
pandemic i've caught up
on some new and old series that i am now
obsessed with
uh today i'm going to share them with
all of y'all so
take notes people
[Music]
okay if you have not seen ted lasso stop
what you're doing and watch it now
i had a day where i had some alone time
and i was it was just me and i literally
started watching it with trisha and eva
my friends
they left my house we have a little
girls thing and
then i watched the rest of them because
i couldn't stop watching
because it's so good i mean it is so
good funny kind of super sad
like but but funny like a dark kind of
comedy kind of way
or comedic kind of way and it's it's
amazing it's
just really he's so positive he's so
positive and i love him you can watch
ted lasso
like with friends i started watching it
during the day with friends and then i
watched the rest of the episodes all in
one night so i could not i was literally
up to like three in the morning which i
don't do
but i could not i had and then i was so
sad
i was so sad when it ended and i won
another season
anyway it's and how it ends is so cute
she's yelling at the window and they're
doing a little
oh i love it anyway you're gonna fall in
love with ted lasso that's it
[Music]
okay so i just found out some news about
bridgerton which if you know me at all
you know i love bridgerton
um and you should watch it and i would
say preferably alone
because don't share that moment with
anyone else but you and duke
stinks speaking of duke hastings i found
out he's not
in the second season uh but i'm pretty
sad i was sad that he wasn't coming back
but it's written so well the music was
so cool how they did
they'll take like modern day songs and
like put a twist on it with like an
orchestra like it's really cool
how they do it and um because i love
duke hastings but i love a lot of the
characters in that show
it's such a well like the cast was it
was so well cast in the
the writing it was so good it was so
good oh i see you library scene with the
stairs
yeah okay happy binge watching and let
me know what i should binge watch
because i love when people tell me
you usually have to tell me like a few
times because there's a lot of things
but
going on but um but i do love watching
really good shows so
let me know i just gave you two amazing
ones you're welcome
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever